welcome back to the machine learning
Street - a YouTube channel with me your
host the X Microsoft tech lead dr. Tim
scarf Lightspeed Yannick Kilcher and
Henry AI labs Connor shorten we have
three incredibly talented researchers
from fair in Paris Marianne lush all
Baptists rosy a and a Gua Liam Lampert
it's incredible having the original
researchers to come on and talk to us
about what their thought process was
having the authors of a paper on the
podcast is always a very special treat
because you can't get to probe not only
the paper itself but the the thinking
process behind it and kind of the
experience is made like look into a real
project of research and that's pretty
cool so here's an example where it's
pretty straightforward idea and it seems
to work pretty well and all that's
required is a little bit of thinking
outside the box so I think this can be
taken as a lesson for the rest of us
they're probably all these things that
no one else thinks to connect to each
other like programming languages and
natural language models I'm sure people
have done it but it seems like with a
little bit of creativity you can do a
lot of cool things in this world I had a
blast doing this and I hope you enjoy as
much as I did this conversation with
these very skilled people have fun now
the really innovative thing they've done
is created an unsupervised language
model for programming languages in
neural machine translation there are
typically lots of examples of language
pairs translating from one thing to
another thing that doesn't really exist
in programming languages so the encoder
part needed to be completely
unsupervised looking at individual
corpora of programming languages now the
way that they've done this is
programming languages have a significant
intersection even if you compare say
Python with something like c-sharp
you'll be surprised that many of the
tokens intersect each other especially
if you break down the tokens using word
piece embeddings which is the modus
operandi in the language processing
world at the moment so it's actually a
reasonably simple idea but they've got
incredible traction with it and it just
works very very well I have
just a big database of documents and
these documents I I know they're all
they're all in English okay and I have
this other big database and I know that
they are all in German I just know their
documents are in German but they don't
correspond to each other they're just
German documents and over here they're
just English documents they don't I
don't say that these two here are
somehow the same no I just have a bunch
of German a bunch range they don't even
have to correspond they're just text and
now what I want to do is I want to learn
a shared embedding space I sort of want
to learn a shared space of embeddings
for these two languages such that
similar things are mapped to the similar
place so if these two documents just
happen to talk about the same thing I
want them to be mapped to similar spaces
in this shared embedding space so I'm
gonna have one model a single model
where I input the text and it goes into
this shared embedding space okay now
this is unusual because usually in
machine translation if you translate
from here from English to German then
you'll have your dedicated model that
takes as English as an input and German
as an output so first of all how do we
make the same model let's say let's say
we have the perfect encoder right this
is e the encoder the same encoder for
all languages let's say we have the
perfect encoder and it can map the if
whenever a sentence means the same thing
in different languages we can completely
map it to the same point in embedding
space irrespective of the language it
comes from one of the things we spoke
about in the show is the potential for
something like this to revolutionize
software engineering maybe in the future
you can use your own programming
language of choice and your IDE or even
github would store an intermediate
representation so currently we have a
real specialization of languages and
lots of people use different languages
for different reasons but something like
this might bridge the gap in a strange
way you can even take it a step further
rather than looking at individual files
you can start to look at entire projects
you could
or the topology of a project perhaps
using a graph spectral representation or
something like that software is still
something that requires human beings
though there's a lot of intelligence
there but there are so many things that
software engineers do which are
repetitive time-consuming tasks and all
of these things either IDE time or a
compilation time or at storage time
could cut the friction out of the
process for us to do software
engineering so it's really really
exciting I'm not sure if that's
Facebook's intention but it could be one
of the consequences of this fascinating
research so the paper we're looking at
today can take the code on the Left
which is written in Python and can
output the code on the right which is
written in C++ now the point here is
that the code on the right does the same
thing as the code on the left so it is
implementing the same function the
surprising thing here is that this model
that takes the Python as an input has
never been explicitly trained to output
C++ so this is an unsupervised
translation model and that's the the
cool thing about this paper is that by
having no supervised signal at
translating source code languages into
one another it can perform pretty well
at the task and nonetheless they say a
trans compiler also known as a source to
source translator is a system that
converts source code from a high-level
programming language such as C++ or
Python to another they say trans
compilers are primarily used for
interoperability and two-port code bases
written in an obsolete or deprecated
language such as cobol or python 2 - a
modern one volume you'd probably
recognize because he's had a lot of work
out recently representing mathematical
equations as well first of all he
decomposes them into a taxonomy and then
he represents them using language and
then of course he can put them into a
Transformers language model and he's got
incredible traction with that Yannick
did a couple of videos on his papers and
even though there are high-level rules
for representing mathematical equations
things like integration are a little bit
more of a black arse
and the incredible thing is that these
language models even though arguably
they're doing pattern recognition
they're doing memorization to a certain
extent they are still very very cleverly
and being able to give you the answer to
these mathematical representations and I
think Hualien is doing some interesting
work at the moment taking that a step
further and being able to automatically
generate mathematical proofs we talked
about some really interesting things in
the show about the the work that they
had done modeling this thing using
transformers it seems at the moment that
you can model almost anything with
transformers and it shouldn't be a
surprise because if you can verbalize
something in language then why not put
it into a Transformers model so that was
really interesting and they talked about
their thought process so when when they
built the encoder how did they test it
how did they verify it was working we
had a bit of a philosophical discussion
about testing and robustness and and how
they think about that I hope this is the
start of many many more similar episodes
to come we are really interested in
talking with the primary authors on the
state-of-the-art deep learning and
research project so please reach out to
us if you are an author or if you know
someone who you think that we should be
talking to please reach out to us so how
does the encoder map the different
languages to the same space such that
the same things are ending up in the
same place it seems it seems a bit
counterintuitive right because it
doesn't know which things correspond to
which things now the first thing you
need is a shared vocabulary here since
we are in a shared space right here the
what you need is a shared vocabulary so
you tokenize all of the text with a
shared vocabulary and this vocabulary is
going to consist of sort of word pieces
now if you don't know what where pieces
are in a word piece tokenization what
you would you already would do is you
would split words into so-called word
pieces so for example hello right here
might be split into two word pieces the
first word piece might be hay and the
second word piece might be ll oh hey
there is usually like some kind of
indicator here that this is the end of a
word and so on but we'll simplify and
hollow right here
would be a a for the first token and
then llo for the second token and these
kind of word peace and codings since the
smallest units are going to be the
characters themselves they ensure that
you always have everything is in
vocabulary you have no out of vocabulary
tokens but here you can already see that
if we tokenize the languages like this
and then we use the same encoder so the
same encoder will pop them into this
shared space that means that to the
model this and this looks like the same
thing it is the same thing right it's
the same input token in different
languages how do we tell the decoder
which is also the same model like how
does it know what to do this is a little
trick where you basically you take this
embedding so you take the input you put
it into your model I don't even know how
you go this and then your output is
going to be autoregressive right so you
decode one token at a time so you decode
this token and then you feed it back
into the model and then you decode this
token you feed that back into the model
and so on this is an auto regressive
language model and the trick here is
that the first the very first token is a
special token that describes the
language you want to output so here you
say I want German and then you let the
model decode it's its thing and by
conditioning on this token right here it
knows it should now produce German you
will simply during training you will
simply put the token here and if it
produces something other than German
that's a loss right so it will learn to
produce German after you produce this
tag remember to Like comment and
subscribe hit that notification bell we
love reading your comments but I've
always I've mispronounced this like a
hundred times people told me in the
comments it's Guillaume not geo yeah
people people in the comments on these
papers they were like our neural
networks just Universal function
approximator x' why is this surprising
and
[Music]
amazing cool well welcome back to the
machine learning Street to a YouTube
channel and podcast we have an
incredible team from fair from Facebook
research and you folks have just
published a really amazing paper doing
it's kind of similar to machine
translation unsupervised but for
programming languages so which one of
you would like to give us the Y elevator
pitch imagine someone's been in a cave
and hasn't heard about the work that
you've done can can one of you give me
the elevator pitch
we basically trained and unsupervised on
SATA which is able to translate between
programming languages and in this paper
we'll test it on Java baton and C++ so
the previous methods that were used to
do that when was she would base and
basically people will just encode a lot
of translation hoops to be able to
perform these sensations and of course
that very time consuming and requires a
lot of expertise in both the source and
target language also this kind of
programs are not be generalizable active
imagery that you already call it
something which is able to translate
from cyberspace to Java and then won't
consent to Titan instead when you
basically need to start all of them
start so that also some machine learning
methods were developed to console you
can okay me languages but they were
often limit reviewed the very limited
amount of data available for programming
languages and there are some examples of
projects that were translated from one
language to another and so it gives some
amount of data but it sent a case for
every language where and generally the
number of examples of functions with a
high translation only in the tens of
thousands and so they were not able to
do that for any non which pair and the
performance were quite limited even when
they were so that's why we decided to
develop a completely unsupervised method
for that
and so we are going to try on a lot more
data and it's very easy to generalize to
more language well because you just need
to code it and some code to tokenize the
input column to determine eyes on the
output and it turns out that it's better
than always meters for Java baton and
superscripts
the interesting bit here is this really
that is it is unsupervised and I've seen
a lot of papers and unsupervised
translation and they kind of try to
align the latent representation and so
on but your paper does something relies
on sort of a different fact namely that
there are some things in these languages
that are actually the same words like in
minimal like min or apps like all kind
of functions like if statements are the
same how how important exactly is that
or could could you get around this like
how many of those overlaps do you really
need to make this work because really
all this model has to go on is these
tokens that are the same I think you
really as you said so one thing that is
very important in supervised machine
translation is to actually learn some
really good cross lingual
representations so your modern as to
learn to align this representation and
it is useful to and needed to to have
some common token in different languages
so with code we have the chance that you
have so all the for while and common
token keyword that you that you
mentioned but you also have all
the variable names that are common
because always English so between the
languages you you find the same and you
also have English talking in the
comments so here we have a lot of common
token that we call anchor points and
they are really really useful and polite
you have this cross lingual
representation and they are needed I
think without that you just can't align
these representations there is a kind of
phylogenetic tree of languages just like
in the animal kingdom that there's a
kind of hierarchy of things inheriting
and composing so what would it mean to
do that in in this cross lingual model
would you ever be able to learn greater
sphere of languages is it is it
something like can you ever can you ever
extract like something higher level or
is it always between like individual
languages right can we ever build
something where we understand all of the
all of the programming languages at the
same time you're looking at leaf nodes
on this phylogenetic tree so you're
looking at let's say Python and C++ or
something it kind of depends then on the
diversity of the languages that you
choose and how much of an overlap they
have have you folks a lot about another
method where you can perhaps learn at
the evolution of the languages and learn
it in a more holistic sense yes so there
was one reason why sir typically what
happens with natural languages is that
so I think it's from this paper of Tomas
McAuliffe in 2013 where they show that
if you train walk to that on English on
you can go to the confront basically
what you read is that you have one set
of embeddings in English on you're the
same one in French on the thing is that
this set of embedding are basically like
almost either metric I means exist a
very simple transformation that can map
the English embeddings to the to the
function buildings which is the rotation
is simple enough and the thing is that I
mean the interesting property here was
that whatever language you consider
whether it's English French Chinese or
any language you can basically find some
some basic ways of mapping between
system which is on the closer they are
so basically the more this mapping can
be orthogonal but in this particular
case of programming language
is what was a bit different was that
unlike in natural language they are
things that you can say in one language
that you can not express in another for
instance pretty much everything you can
say in English you can say in French
except a few idioms but apart from this
pretty much everything can be collected
on this also this property holds for any
language but in by phone on let's say by
fancy press play soccer ball there are
things that you can write in one
language that cannot easily be
translated to zero so this is why there
is not like a perfectly this mapping
doesn't exist or if it exists it's
definitely not trivial at all this is
why we were not really sure that this
was going going to work so the approach
that we used here was a bit different
typically for natural languages what we
did was that we actually started from
this one Dominic so that we train some
modern weddings in the two languages we
find the alignments on them we start
from this so here this will not probably
this will not have worked this approach
typically if you try not to like on some
C++ token and some Python tokens I
really doubt that we will have observed
this and mapping between these two
languages I mean typically everything
that corresponds to Mumbai in Python
there will have been nothing
corresponding aqua zeros in the other
languages so there is this mapping will
not existed on it's unclear how it will
develop this is why we actually employ
distracted if you want that portion
which was to build on top of xlm where
here the pre training is done by
actually learning just a big notch model
on the concatenation of all of system
Wendy's on this is where the alignment
happens basically like with my instead
with a cue ball that are in common but
also other commands looked so English
commanded people writing the code which
is the same actually language yeah could
you maybe take us through the just kind
of through how you come up with a
research idea like this because because
it's I mean it's it's so improbably that
you one day you just be under the shower
and you're like hey I could you know
apply these three wildly different
things you know programming languages
and unsupervised translations and same
tokenizer x' how what angle did you come
from how did you develop the idea itself
I think a lot of people are you know
struggling to actually come up with even
ideas of what to research yes so we were
thinking that all the advents we were
seeing sorry that all the events in the
instrumentation
session work very well for all natural
languages for only turn now images that
don't where you don't have access to any
actual actually parallel data so we were
seeking that as for programming
languages you don't have any parallel
data but you have access to a lot of
monolingual data and this unsupervised
machine translation models work very
well for natural languages when you have
a lot of modern equal data were thinking
that as you can soak a nice code the
same way that actually you took a nice
sum with different tokenizer but you can
took in high school and make sequences
the same way as you do for natural
languages we said that it could be a
good fit actually for programming
languages - yeah - try these these
methods and so we we wanted to try and
we thought I actually that because you
have these anchor points that Gilman and
I told you about this this was a reason
why plus the fact that you have a lot of
monolingual data it was two reasons why
it could work so we wanted to try did
you the what what was in making it work
what was like the biggest the biggest
point where it didn't work because it in
these papers you know it always seems
like and then you write a beautiful blog
post and everything just happens to be
so like like the outcome is extremely
pretty
right these you can translate between
these functions and so on but like from
experience at some point in the middle
you're just like this this is never
gonna work right i this is
insurmountable what was sort of the
stepping stones and where did you run
into problems how did you fix them okay
actually I think you are going to be
disappointed but everything worked and
where we weren't very like no that's
true yes yeah so the timeline was like
we first wanted you to try to train the
the language model just to see if the
model can can learn this course lingual
representations because if if it cannot
then you can't
so this was really our first step so the
first thing we did was to after
processing purposing and tokenizing the
the code we learned this language model
and the first thing that we do was just
to test it so to see if the crossing
where representation are our learnt so
we we first check the token embeddings
and to see when looking at a one token
for instance one key word like I don't
know int if what are the nearest
neighbors and to see if the nearest
neighbors are integer or an equivalent
in another language and actually it was
the case so for first it was like a real
good step because we saw that crossing
where representation alert and the
second thing with this language model is
we try to generate some code just to see
the language model and learn to generate
some syntactically
accurate code so we try to on the
notebook just-just-just this to to give
like the beginning of a function and to
see if the modem was able to generate
the the end of the function and actually
it did so we were like okay so the model
is able to learn crossing representation
is able to generate some syntactically
correct code so we were amazed and we
was like ok this is a really good step
to keep going and then we we learn so
the step two to translate and again we
we just test our model on on a netbook
and we gave like a little function in
Python to see if it can translate into
another language and again it was it was
working and so after we just add it was
not a problem but the the
men like afford that we had to do is to
to have an actual metric to evaluate or
model not just to mm netbook and to have
a parallel tested because we didn't have
any so we add two to create one so as we
explained in the paper we extracted one
from from the site gig for gigs and we
we we run we build some unit tests to
test the generate generated function and
we we try to find a baseline because
when you have some score you don't have
any any baton we come we can say that
yes it's work know if it's it's kind of
art you to to see so we took the the
commercial one two ways and that our
rules made bedlam and we were better
than the one commercial whose bass bass
line so we were like that's amazing and
then yeah we were the paper so we didn't
yeah everything worked well so I'm quite
interested in your process you said for
example it's it's analogous to word to
Beck in some in some ways and what you
might do interactively on a word to Veck
model is runt is knee or something and
look at the projected position of the
words and you would see that words that
are semantically similar would be very
close to each other and I don't know
would you would you just do that
interactively or
would you come up with rules so that you
know that you're the architecture and
the way you're training the model is
going in the right direction how are you
reasoning about the the behavior of the
encoder yet we just tested took any
meetings we didn't test down the old
sentence submitting because it was much
harder to test actually yeah
it's because you gave the example before
of you it take int and something else
and you would look at the cosine
distance or something did you just come
up with a load of those rules and use
that as a test bed or was it how did you
quantify it we just look at the maybe
you can say more because you did this
part but we just look at the nearest
neighbor in all our dictionary and just
to see if this nearest neighbor as a as
meaning or it just like random we didn't
really quantify it with just a synonym
on a few example and
since it was working on all of them
almost all of them consolidated was we
didn't need to go any further
that's fascinating I suppose the reason
I was asking the question before is
clearly for example English is a
Germanic language and if you look at the
evolutionary tree we inherit a lot from
Latin but we we don't have any
intersection with Arabic languages so it
stands to reason that if you take a
couple of languages in Europe there'd be
a significant intersection and it would
work very well using your method but
sometimes it wouldn't work and I just
wondered whether you had a formalism of
reasoning about at what point does it
stop working and what factors
influencing we don't know exactly what
kind of performance we will get if we're
who used this one Delta to translate
from Kabul to C++ for instance because I
mean even the follow Saudi France isn't
the right
additions and notification don't always
use the mathematical operators like in
Java C++ and paper so they will
definitely be a lot less uncle cones and
maybe it wouldn't work as well with this
version and we find some some more
things to make it work - they consist so
you have someone buildings for your
English rods but what we did was
basically trying to artificially modify
the overlap between two languages by
putting some uppercase like before in
one language so that you come back you
cannot have this match on simply that
and that was still kind of working so on
the even some experiments where we
aligned English to English but my
trainings
what I mean use individual interest
environment was always perfect you want
them to share a common ancestor but how
far away that ancestor is seems to be
relevant and I just wonder is this an
example of where you might impute some
kind of prior into your language model
so you understand what the evolutionary
tree is and if two languages do share a
common ancestor but the distance between
them is quite far could you augment them
by finding to intermediate languages and
training on those as well yes so what we
try to do so for instance there are some
languages like you
yeesh on the Nepali so if you trained in
spies machine translation systems
between these two languages it doesn't
work really well so one issue is that is
that there is absolutely no overlap
between English on the politics it's not
the same alphabet so what is working so
is that if you train click on your model
with English Nepali but also Hindi so in
this using the same alphabet as dabeli
and also in the indica Pro if you have
English with English words which in
practice upon diminish happen in the
copies that we do not have English words
on there so if you train a natural I
mean if you train them knowledge
modalities for languages basically you
will improve the performance basically
between in the soy between English on
Nepali so having like some languages in
the middle which is connected to the two
can actually improve the performance
between these two very foul language is
so it's actually what we did for English
to Nepali translation and you can
actually go from a government from like
tubular Scot like 15 or something like
this so it's actually it makes it one of
the one of the things with languages is
right they can not share the tokens and
so on and then they can become hard like
COBOL and C++ and so on but there are
other things that I kind of came to my
mind where you actually do share the
tokens but that might not fall under the
traditional view of programming language
so things like like pseudo code they
share a lot of tokens right they share
but the pseudo code everyone write
pseudo code a bit different and then
like something like UML diagrams like
there are lots and lots all these other
people in companies they write their UML
diagrams their class diagrams and their
methods and their dependencies and so on
and there should be a significant
overlap between that and variable names
and class names and so on can you ever
think of maybe something like this would
work where you can specify like a UML
diagram and then generate the the code
for it with the implementations of the
functions or something like this or
would this be completely out of scope
yeah so first of all pseudo code I think
that the main difference between pseudo
code and real code is that folks who
look at the syntax is not as three
and I would expect our model to welcome
pseudocode as well because basically
could share a lot of syntax
the forms are basically now you'll swap
words or generally define the operations
with the mathematical operators just
like in baton sequence person Java I
think the main issue will be to find a
laughs at a set of that's not as easy to
find as for programming languages and it
would be much more difficult to test but
I think it would be doable like we also
have to wonder whether it would be very
useful because as I'm not sure it's much
easier to do - why - pseudocode
then - right and just send program in a
language of your choice so I'm not sure
there will be that many users for
something like that but they definitely
it would be inclusive and quite
interesting for you I meant diagrams
I have standard that familiar with UML
diagrams but I think it would be much
more difficult to get cost incurred on
building between the UML diagrams and
some code in C++ or Java like yeah
I would expect that even if there is
some overlap on the class names and
function names you will have lesser
coupons and I expect it will be much
harder to find enough uncle cons to get
to truly were embedding if you had a
very big data sets of parallel data
between well-meant diagrams and classes
that implement this UML diagrams you
could do something you will have some
other problems with take care of because
if it's a UML diagram for many classes
and academic project you will run into
some memory issues but I guess there
will be some ways to go on that like
maybe to generate the classes only one
by one to have a way to distribute your
data on many machine at the same time
but I guess in that case it will be
whoever
I mean what what I find so interesting
about these neural approaches where you
actually learn on a data set compared to
these rule-based things is that if I
apply the rule based thing it will
surely be correct but it will I will
probably not understand it right it's
like you know if I write my typescript
and I transpile it to JavaScript it
looks like garbage
it looks and if I minify it even more
what I love about these methods is that
they they take the human element into
account and they really it really shows
you that programming we think of it as a
computer language but it programming is
a human language because I can write the
same function in one way where everyone
on the world that can code understands
it and in another way where I play I
play vim golf or I play Perl golf and
you know no one understands what I'm
doing is is this on your mind like does
this so I had this thought of can can we
write for example a decompiler that goes
like let's say we would have some
anchors for assembler or something this
would be like the perfect decompiler no
because it would not only generate the
C++ code that generates that assembly
but it would generate it in a way that D
like a human would yeah and I think for
a G combination as you can like take
your code compile it to a decimal you
could actually you you can train it in a
supervised way yeah so you don't even
need anchor points because in a super
bit yeah so yeah I think it could be
something as that you can do and you
don't even have to to use the
unsupervised methods but just like the
traditional as a vise method so yeah I
think it could have an even smarter idea
[Laughter]
if you folks could go back and do it in
a completely different way I mean for
example one thing you might do is trying
to predict the abstract syntax tree or
having more of a structured approach
rather than letting the machine learning
algorithm do everything I really like
what Yannick said before because there
is a bit of an art to it it's very
similar to the mathematics paper that a
guellen wrote which was he I think he
described in the paper that integration
is the black art of the mathematics
world and sometimes having fixed rules
isn't very good there is a bit of a
pattern recognition aspect to it and I
suppose that that's actually a really
good thing about the work that you folks
have done here our model is completely
unconstrained so the good thing about it
is that can generate anything and can
sometimes generate some code that is
that looks more like what women do
that's nonsense
if you generate a phone if you follow if
the body of your for loop takes only one
line you can choose you can choose to
omit the curly brackets and that's
something that humans often do and
omitted can do that as well when
otherwise wouldn't be able to do that
and also more importantly issue and if
show Adelle generates an AST do we need
a meter to training that will be a lot
slower like 3 LS gems up
that's for world train because you
before you generated the if token you
don't know what you what kind of thing
do we need to generate afterwards and so
we think that methods that generate a
HTS very good for supervised model that
walk with little data because in that
case it's not really a problem if it's
slow to Train and maybe the extra well
these are constraints that you put on
the output of the model will really give
a big boost in Timnath in terms of
performance
but first because we turn on a lot of
data actually our Moodle is pretty good
at learning the syntax we are not
totally convinced that we would really
get a big boost in terms of performance
by generating an ASD however saying that
we think that we could do some things at
evaluation time to constrain our model
to generate something that combines and
the data that we have shows that it's
something that could really help
especially for the Java to C++ pair
action both directions most of the
errors appeared compilation time so
there are differences and things we
could do that learning a sorting
algorithm for example you need to have a
dense sampling of the input space you
probably need to have every permutation
as an example to train on and clearly
you could just write a few lines of code
which we generalize much better what are
your thoughts on that well I guess in
your in your system as it appears to me
it's it's pretty cool because you
combined the two right you combine the
human intelligence that writes the code
in one language and the machine
intelligence to pattern pattern it over
to the other languages I think it's a
good example of how these two work in
synergy rather than in in opposition to
each other and we don't have to do
through that deep learning do every I
think Young Lacan just tweeted out
yesterday or something that pretty
amazing and it was like deep learning
system lands Boeing 767 like no no no no
never
Yan laocoon pointed out we don't
understand how the wings work on an
aircraft I was reading an article the
other day by that Kassie lady from
Google that she posed a philosophical
question would you rather fly on a plane
where you understood how it all worked
but it had never been tested or would
you rather fly in a plane that had been
tested thoroughly I think in that case
whether you can understand the system
dimensionally system only matters if see
if you think it's a good works if how
well it will generalize to other test
sets I would like if the plane was
tested in real situations I will try to
machine on in system more even though I
don't understand
they would test the machine on its
system that is understandable more when
I don't really tell the test set when I
think that the test that doesn't really
correspond to what I actually want to
use this system on production but
otherwise if neither set is exactly
corresponds exactly to the use case I
want and then I don't think I need from
this on what the system does unless
there some legal reasons for all but you
could argue that even if it generalized
to the test set that was still local
generalization and clearly in these high
dimensional semantically complex data
sets that we're working with there will
be many things that we might see in
production that were not in the test sir
yeah you sure if your test set is some
part of your collection data and if
you're confident enough that the world
is not changing too fast and that this
part of your production data that you
got at that time is still relevant today
something that you can close the other
thing is chalette says in these
perception type tasks and I would
include language in that for the work
that William did on mathematics that
there is a subjective element to it
we're not in the rules-based world here
but we could take it a step further what
do you folks think we could do to
revolutionize software development what
if I no longer have to know multiple
languages what if I could just use any
language I wanted to on a particular
coding file and the IDE or even get
would actually learn an intermediate
representation could we revolutionize
software with something like this well
let me expand on that question a bit are
you trying to revolutionize software
engineering or is this just is this just
basically it's just as you being
researchers or is there actually
something that you're pushing for here
so it's I think when we did the project
was not just for research but really we
wanted to to make it work and make it
used but we don't think that with the
performance that we have now this is
something that can like really
revolution I think we still need to we
don't want to replace software engineers
we want to maybe add them but not
replace
because with the system that we have no
way we eat again apps to translate
function but you still need to have a
software engineer that check that the
function is correct and to translate all
projects you still need some work
so we want this tool to be to be used
but we don't we don't take in cat
revolution all the world of the computer
science word and and replace all the so
for engineers because we read something
like that but no we don't think so
maybe Excel said to revolutionizing
software and we hope that ice and some
other people will build upon that and
that that's at some point is revolution
with the chip so a related question may
be what what is because I've been
wondering about this if generally about
the research labs and these big
companies Facebook as a company it's
like it's not they don't have like an
IDE that they're you know developing
they don't they're not you know do they
I don't think they own github they might
by now but so so is there like a a
product push from the Facebook side or
is it or more generally how much how
much do you in the research lab have to
go towards a product of the company or
how much are you basically just do
whatever you want I think there is a lot
of freedom basically in what researchers
and engineers can walk on basically
people are free to walk and whatever you
think is interesting it's kind of
fundamental research lab and so people
work and some thing that are very
practical like machine translation
follow we saw some widgets for instance
something that is very useful to to
Facebook but some people work and some
very theoretical aspects of things by
banana and some like reinforcement
running for gaming's like stack up
constants so it doesn't have to be
something which is necessary useful for
the Facebook website there is the
research shop is not designed to
actually develop things that are useful
for the website but when it is useful
then it's it's definitely good I mean
people usually like to see the things
put into production and see that there
is such actually like really useful but
it's encourage basic yeah and then once
research is used to be useful for
projection it's not the team of fair
that is going to put it in prediction
then there is some discussion and
collaboration between some prediction
team and the research team so basically
we do the research and then if it's
useful other production team are going
to use it and and work with us too to
put it in production that's very cool
so it's not it's not really you don't
really have to orient yourself towards a
product no how much do you have to
orient yourself towards what the senior
research and maybe give listen away or
this one I don't actually have to orient
yourself to what the seniors want or how
much are these ideas coming bottom-up
because I'm very I know academia right
and here you know it things work maybe a
little bit different how much is their
top like how often does young lacan show
up and say here is a research direction
right this is what we're going to do as
a team or how often do you come and say
look here is something really cool that
I would like to investigate
she literally depends on who your
advisor is and we have senior leaders
but generally people are very very free
to do what they what they want to do and
I think that everyone can come up with
an idea and come to see his or her dizer
saying oh I won't welcome this thing and
expect you that person who at least
listened to let me personally I feel
they can feel free to do what I feel is
interesting but like for election
academia it's not always the case for
everyone but in general people are
pretty free to stand and sometimes
during my death Facebook it was the same
for me it was basically I don't even
know a single instance where somebody
wanted to work on something but he's
always manager or supervisor always
telling me that maybe should focus on
some fears in instead I mean people of
course I mean people are advised but
basically in the end it's so this reason
basically is to say man is given to them
yeah and for me because we all have
different roles interfere so I am a
recent an engineer and
engineer you you can choose the project
you want to work on and the scientists
you want to work with and then your
manager basically always say yes so yeah
as a research engineer you can you can
you can choose any project you want and
when I joined Facebook I was very junior
so I didn't lead any project
scientifically I mean I was more like
following but the more you grow in
facebook AI the more you can you can
choose and even there are some engineers
that come up with some idea without any
scientist and they can leave that
project so I think it's pretty free
amazing what do you folks think about
the state of deep learning at the moment
what a question what what excites you
where do you think it's gonna go in the
next five years
yeah I think that's something which is
currently missing is it related to
everything we've we've been discussing
so far which is great it was I mean the
ability of these modules to actually do
a zoning for instance it is an inverter
so interpretability for instance if you
do some question answering you ask a
question to your mother you use a
monster so can you explain you why the
context menu I use its output and not
something else and can you actually even
when you perform some integration or if
you output function can you guarantee
that this is correct and these are
basically some way to have a model which
is not cool based but you know that can
local manipulate symbolic elements for
instance not be not only doing some
fuzzy reasoning on the GS the answer on
the New York you manually check that the
answer is correct can you have some
defending model that can actually a
guarantee that whatever else are telling
you is correct basically other thing is
this will not go without interfaith
ability I think it's all these things
are a bit related under so yeah like
it's basically the way the ability of
these models to manipulate some discrete
elements some symbolic elements like
there's a combination of like oh this
continues and continues representations
inside this model I think is something
which is currently missing and that
people actually are currently trying to
do do you think interpretability even
exists because it can tell you the what
but not the how and for example Chalet
advocates for program synthesis
and if you generate a skill program
that's computer code again and you can
verbalize what it's doing but could you
could you ever understand what a deep
learning model is doing I think it will
depend on its architecture but if it's
if it's manipulating some discrete
element if it's manipulating some
symbols within its illinois or something
like this i think that it would be it
would be much easier to understand what
is going on
you will not have basically like 24
layers of like fraud
I mean continuous lectures and then the
output you will have education you'll be
able to select the connection between
the elements of course it will still at
the end be a bit fuzzy but you I think
you get more insights about whether it
is correct or not it's certainly Spencer
that where I think it will definitely
help or soit probably will improve the
ability of ML to generalize so so yeah
something like this I think basically
putting some constraints on the
architecture so that your model is
actually manipulating some things that
you can actually where I could formalize
on the trickery understand is very
difficult it's something that a lot of
people have tried to do but it's it's
differently I think one of the things
that we are missing right now if we want
to make progress we had the expert
systems in the 1980s and we would
construct these large knowledge graphs
and they had some advantages but the
disadvantage was we had to create them
manually and they were very brittle
they didn't scale very well you can ask
GPT any question and it will just give
you the answer straight away so that's
really really good in a way we want that
but I guess we also want to have what we
don't have which is understanding the
behavior and we don't want the
memorization we want some kind of
abstraction and reasoning to allow us to
have more generalization we we seem to
be stuck in a bit of a rut at the moment
in the deep learning world what do you
think of the scaling debate like what do
you make of all of this notion that the
more we scale our models the better they
go especially in language models right
we just see like models and models and
models they just pack on the layers and
the transformer heads and the inner
dimensions and the perplexity just goes
down and down and down you having having
worked a bit with a different sort of
language let's say that data how can how
can one make sense of this
like how is this not overfitting how is
this how does this work
yeah so I think what is interesting is
to indeed look at the performance that
you can get by just scaling up these
models for instance what opinio is doing
with a GPT I think it's it's very
interesting
I mean basically we still don't really
know like what easy make performance
that we get by just like scaling things
even more but but yeah I think in the
end we I mean constancy basically add
some some really good results on pretty
much all the tasks like constellation
impression and so on everything but
there was some task parallelism where
they were struggling for instance doing
some addition of digits or like
multiplication which I think enough
shows a kind of the limitation for what
we will do by just scaling current
models without having some significant
change in the faculty or something like
this so I think it's very interesting to
see how far we can go by just scaling
things but in the end I mean particular
that we're gonna need something else but
it's up here what we I mean we still
don't know what we have we have made a
thread on reddit to collect a bunch of
questions and there are a few so we can
just maybe quickly address them Thunder
Jack's asks are you planning to open
source the code have you open sourced
the code yeah we're planning to open to
Zuko's we're working on this note so we
are going to open throws the co to train
the model to process a process github
the same way we did we are also are
going to open source a parallel test set
and all the unit tests that we built so
in order that people can just test them
without at the same way we did and all
the code to evaluate a model and yes
finally we are going to also open so the
weights of our model so in order that
people that counts between the model can
can use the weights so we are going to
open source all of this awesome we've
kind of touched on this but a jolt unit
asks what happens when a trans Cody
encounters a language feature in one
language that is not available in
another language for instance interfaces
or asynchronous code would seem to be
challenging to translate into Python so
it's sort of what we've discussed with
the non-overlapping
Ekans but have you seen what happens
when you have an entire let's say
construct or feature of a language that
that isn't available does the model work
around it or does it just fail yes who
typically fits for instance if you know
if the function is in pattern in
schooling and something like is instance
that doesn't really exist in C++ or Java
a library like bundles that doesn't
really have an equivalent Bible in C++
and the mother is going to fail to put
the collector put because he I mean
ideally put will beat who just like
Heidi world Ponder's libraries and to
output that but it's not able to do it
what she does is that sometimes he just
output something that is incorrect and
sometimes it will output something that
just assumes that you already created a
class in Java that does whatever conda's
is doing in this function that you want
to translate and it calls some functions
there that don't really someone else's
problem
yeah okay open a I released an
autoregressive computer code
autocomplete a thing which you spoke
about unit that the way you folks have
approached it is slightly different but
what was really cool about that demo was
inside an IDE you could do code
completion I just wonder what kind of
use cases could you do with with your
kind of model so for the encoder folks
are using some kind of a denoising
auto-encoder a bert type model but what
kind of features could you add to an IDE
given that representation you know could
you do some kind of personalization for
example if we add just one predictor
representation for one one sentence for
instance when the line for instance
instruction like OS that remove or
something like that it would be very
interesting if we could have just one
vector presentation and then looking at
the nearest neighbor to suggest
alternatives to just yet to have other
way to to implement things but in order
to do that we need to because to to
reduce all the output of the transformer
to just one vector but but if we could
do that I think it could be very
interesting but it need to be the more
work I think that's fascinating there is
so much untapped potential here just
imagine at the moment you can learn a
really good representation of a piece of
code but what if you looked at all of
the projects on github and and learned
the topology of all of the files in a
given project and you can embed all of
these into some vector space and we're
almost taking a step towards being able
to create software automatically be able
to interpolate between two software
programs and what would that mean yeah
it seems it seems that it's it's not
like something that will at some point
be possible with machine learning but
that sounds also very difficult I mean I
think there are many things that we can
do with machine learning for code
generation on people are only starting
to look at what is possible and I mean I
think like when for instance like twenty
years ago the automated machine
translation system in English French it
was very bad on nobody was using that I
mean professional translators would
never look into this but no it's really
good and even professional actually use
that and I think for a similar
phenomenon will be observed in I think
in programming languages
some point maybe like in five years I
don't know I think that either like
machine translation system will be good
enough maybe they will be good enough in
like Python suppose that people will
actually find it useful it will never be
perfect but I think it's going to be
good enough that actually people
actually have a poor I mean find it
interesting to use it like English
crunch to the Google concert is not
perfect but still people find it very
very useful and I think something
similar will be observed for gaming and
wedges so the task of a was natural
language to code generation so you
actually write a sentence on the middle
if you like some some code I think it's
very difficult and I do know when
something like this would be like fully
operational but just simply translating
function I think is something much
simpler on it could be useful like I
think very soon like maybe very cool I
guess I'm just excited about the
possibilities you can do so much more
than say with an auto regressive
language model there's so much structure
to a programming project just that the
names of the files the relationships
between the files the dependencies in
the files you could model all of that
and I would say there are so many
intersections between different software
projects so it almost seems that I could
just start to create a software project
and you would be able to predict what I
was trying to do in automate a lot of
that away so I think that's fascinating
but another question I'd like to ask is
this is to all of you what's the most
important thing that you've learned in
the last year something that people
cannot for already know since a long
time ago but I mean this is a fact that
I mean in machine learning for no really
I mean one of the thing that really
works the most is just to basically
increase the data size for instance in
natural language I mean in numbers media
you just have to ignore that in machine
translation is probably machine
translation you don't have any file that
does what you do basically create a
variant that that was bad connotation
like in a symbolic mathematics basically
what we what we just did you know if it
was simply create like millions of
equations and people I think try often
to come up with complicated
architectures on a complex systems but
basically
I mean just like granular transformers
with very very large datasets I think we
can do a lot of things I think it's not
it's not clear how far we will be able
to go with just buy me a transformers if
read extremely large copper eyes so I
think for now it's basically the
importance of the data in whatever task
we consider like how important it is
that it's much there are so many very
complicated thing that people do like
for manipulating equations we like some
pre based models the just like a simple
model with a lot of the tests with
enough so I think it's for all of the
project I've been working on it's these
things that you just need to find a way
to generate metal generators on that's
pretty much you can go get a car with
this that's amazing
there have been so many applications for
the Transformers architecture
I think open AI have just applied it to
doing Auto regressive pixel-by-pixel
predictions for reconstructing images
and you applied it to modeling complex
mathematical formulas you turn them into
an expression tree and then you
transform that into a language
expression and put them into a
transformers model that fascinates me
how many other applications do you think
that we can apply to this follow what we
are exploring is so we are in a
generation again but we are also looking
into theorem proving
automated theorem proving constants see
if you can actually take some some
conjecture or some theorems that that is
difficult to prove and see whether
Armadale can actually generate a formal
proof of this statement under it's
something which currently doesn't work
really well I mean like ultimately that
you're improving is a pretty old feel
like like several decades but it's for
no I mean it really it doesn't work
really well I mean even really like
trivial statements it's very hard I mean
you generate automatic proof for that
and I think that deep learning we also
work very well here basically the task
is just how do you apply depending to
this particular problem under yeah it's
something we are looking at what's
fascinating about it is shortcuts exist
in mathematics where is for something
like a sorting algorithm there are no
shortcuts is it tells us things about
maths that perhaps we didn't know yeah
it's very possible that modèle actually
finds an alternative proof to like a
problem I think it's I mean it depends
depends on what is a parameter
to solve what kind of exercises for
instance if it's and if it's something
like high school problem and if the
solution is not very complicated there's
not so many ways to access it but if
it's some very complicated conjectures
usually they are built on top of
different theories on there are many
ways to reach the final solution I mean
there are conjectures that we mean very
simple problems that we actually took
centuries to solve but then we actually
found very very different truths over
the time it's possible that actually
machine answers to do something exists I
mean it's it's gonna long term but it's
yeah since you're all at at Facebook is
there anything that maybe you've seen
into somewhere else or something is
there anything that is special about
Facebook AI research compared to maybe
other research labs compared to academia
or something like this because just to
get you know for people to have an
impression of what it's like to be there
specifically yeah I couldn't say
anything about that because this is the
first place where I work in research so
I don't know how it is I swear so I
can't in service sorry yeah I think
compared to to to some other places you
get to meet a lot of people everyone
isn't questioning what everyone else is
doing and you get to meet a lot of
people very easily or so because we all
eat together and for lunch and dinner
and so you get to know that everyone's
project and I feel like compared to some
other places were at what I was only
getting to know people my immediate team
very well I'm meeting a lot more people
and I am learning about a lot more
different projects well I'm personally
incredibly jealous I think you folks are
living the dream you were working on
cutting edge deep learning for Facebook
research so incredibly jealous yeah I
think I could just say one thing it's
not Owen conversion with other places
but one thing that I'm impressed at
Facebook AI is that everyone is like
very
fascinated by what is doing and so like
ideas arguing everywhere and everyone
loves I think what it does and I think
it's really make a difference because
they everyone like a pleasure to as
Betty said to to discuss everything even
at lunch or after work and and this
atmosphere are like loving what you're
doing I think it's really making a
difference and this is really the case
here I think amazing well in which case
I think we should we should round this
episode after folks thank you so much
honestly if your work is inspirational
we really appreciate you coming on the
show you release your next paper you
have to promise to come back thank you
remember to Like comment and subscribe
hit that notification bell we love
reading your comments